hey everyone it's sarah stanner sorry
end comm and in this video i'm gonna
demonstrate for you how to administer
nitro bid which is not your glycerine
appointment first what you want to do is
you want to gather your supplies so
you'll need to get your nitro bid nitro
glycerine pointment and a lot of them
come in tubes like this or they come in
like little foil packages so get
whatever your facility has you will
definitely need to get an application
paper this is so important because this
allows you to measure how many inches of
ointment you're going to get like half
an inch an inch and they come in like a
little booklet like this you can tear
off in your Omni cell whatever you have
that dispenses medication and get one of
these papers you also need to get some
gloves to protect yourself from this
ointment because if you get
nitroglycerin on you this ointment it
will cause a headache and cause you to
feel flushing and things like that and
you don't want to experience that you
need some tape to secure down the
application papers along with some
Tegaderm or plastic wrap to cover the
application site because nitroglycerin
can stain the clothing along with a
cloth for whenever you remove the old
application paper from the skin just to
clean off that excessive amount of
nitroglycerin that will be left behind
after you gather your supplies you'll
want to do the patient's five right so
make sure you have the right patient you
have the right drug the right dose the
right time and the right route now
whenever you're giving nitroglycerin
appointment you want to watch out for
some things number one you want to make
sure the patient's blood pressure is
good they don't have hypotension and you
want to warn your patient that you know
this may cause a headache if this is
really the first time receiving it it
can also cause warmness and flushing in
the space another thing is you need to
know what nitroglycerin pointment is
used for it's typically used to prevent
chest pain in patients with coronary
artery disease so if you're working on a
cardiac floor you'll probably be giving
a lot of nitro Paste so the first thing
what you want to do is you want
to remove the old application paper
first that contains the nitroglycerin
before we actually put on the new one so
you want to wash your hands and you want
to wear gloves very important never do
this without gloves because there's
still nitroglycerin on the skin and if
you get this on you you will get some
side effects of nitroglycerin and you
don't want that so we are going to take
it off and gently just remove the tape
from the site and if you have trouble
finding where the the applicator pad is
just ask the patient and just look
everywhere you can find them on the arm
on the chest on the back sometimes maybe
the patient's bed if they've came off so
just always try to look for it and then
you're just gonna take it off notice
there's still some nitro and then just
gently fold this together and discard
then take your cloth and gently just
wipe off the area of the excessive
nitroglycerin now we're going to place a
new applicator pad somewhere else and
again we can use the arm the chest the
back but you always want to rotate sites
after doing that you want to perform
hand hygiene then you want to prep your
application paper and what we're gonna
do is we're going to date and time it
and initial it and then we're going to
square the ointment on to the scale so
where we're going to write our date and
time and initials is on the printed side
because on this opposite side without
the print is where we are going to
measure the pointment and you can see
through the onto the other side because
it's paper so thin so you can measure it
a lot of people ask well why don't we
just measure it on the side with the
scale it's because whenever the
pointment comes into contact with this
print it can cause the print to leak
into the ointment and we don't want to
get that on the patient so we're gonna
go ahead and date time and initial it
and don't date in time over the scale
because when you flip it over you won't
be able to see the scale whenever you're
measuring out the pointman
so right
somewhere where you have access to it
and it's best to use one of these
markers if you can because it shows up
better than a pen okay now we're going
to flip it over and we're going to
measure out our point Minh and the
doctors order says one inch of Nitra bid
point Minh so to do that we are going to
daughter gloves now let's open our
pointment tubing okay if this is the
first time you're opening up this point
mandir is a special way you have to open
it and for this video this is a demo
dose of nitroglycerin pointment it's not
the real thing in there we're just using
this for teaching purposes so what you
want to do is you want to unscrew this
cap and on this side of the cab is like
this beveled area that's sort of pointy
it's going to screw into the top of this
tubing and it'll poke a hole in it so
you can squirt out the ointment so take
that and just insert it in there and
just screw it on a little bit like that
and see it allows your ointment to come
out now we're going to squirt out one
inch of paste okay so looking at your
scale from here to here is half an inch
and from here to here is an inch and so
we're going to squirt the ointment from
here to there so let's do that
okay and we have an inch so we picked
the other arm to place our new
application paper with appointment and I
made sure that it was intact there's no
areas that are open and there it's free
from hair if it had a lot of hair we
want to trim it not shave it and I
wanted to make sure that the site was
clean so now we're just going to apply
our paper to it and to do that we are
going to put the ointment side on to the
skin and we're just going to thinly
spread it at the side don't rub it in
don't massage it just thinly spread it
so it's evenly dispersed like that now
we're going to secure it to keep it in
place so you can use a Tegaderm plastic
wrap whatever you have access to and
just cover the site and then tape it
into place
okay and then the patient is ready to go
until their next dose after you're done
with that discards your gloves perform
hand hygiene and then chart that you
gave them medication and where you place
that applicator pad so the next nurse
can find it and just a quick tip I
wanted to go over real quick with you is
about this nitro pointment and some
places keep it in the tubing like here
and if this is the case with your
facility because it's multi patient use
you can use it for your patient several
times in the tube you'll put like their
patient label on it you want to keep
this in the designated area that your
hospital wants you to keep it not in the
patient's room and their drawer or
something like that because one time
this nurse told me that she had a
patient and she walked into the room and
the wife was giving the patient a
massage a back massage and she was using
this ointment because she found the
women in the patient's drawer and
thought it was just some type of lotion
she could use and both her both the
patient and the patient's wife had an
adverse reaction to it so just to
protect your patient their family
members and yourself always keep this in
the designated place set by your
Hospital okay so that wraps up how to
administer nitroglycerin
thank you so much for watching and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
more videos